If we talk about our alimentary canal,
then our alimentary canal starts
from the mouth where the
digestion of our carbohydrates starts.
This mouth leads you
into the oral cavity or the buccal cavity,
after this it opens your mouth.  In the pharynx,
it will send food particles to your esophagus. Then,
from the esophagus, the food
goes to your stomach, where the digestion of proteins
starts, as well as it
can store food for four to four years.  The food that is there will
go to your small intestine, which are your paths?
Denum jejunum ileum, here your
food particle goes, then it
goes to our large intestine, where basically
your cecum, colon and rectum come and at
last, which is your  Undigested food material is
excreted out of the body through our anal canal and anus.